have you ever driven the bus yeah i
don't think that'd be a good idea
what's up gq i'm justin bieber come
check out my tour bus
[Music]
so here's my layer here's where i watch
the toronto maple leafs um absolutely
demolish the ottawa senators
it's 5'4 it's looking good
here's where i set up i sit here and i
do work
when we're on the road i sit here and i
get emails done and stuff
[Music]
there is a it's not real but it's a
fireplace here which is kind of cool
aesthetic
we got some art here by
my friend joe termini and it's
uh some of my favorite art it's called
cash only
you can check it out here
bus memory wow okay well one time it was
me
alfredo and another friend
and we made this music video it was
really
low quality we made it on like a flip
cam or something
and it was like a 10 hour bus ride and
we made this video to a drake song
called uh find your loving i better find
you
love it i don't know if that's what the
song is called but anyways we were on
the bus and we had strobe
like just not real strobe lights but we
had like uh
flashlights and we just made this
mockery music video and it was fun
and then back here is my bedroom this is
where i will sleep on the road when i
[Music]
travel
[Music]
so um on the road uh this is where i
where i sleep so i spend most of my time
back here
laying down watching movies getting rest
but check this out
we got a shower it has
a steam feature in it which is pretty
cool
and then here is an infrared sauna
which is my favorite what's so cool
about this is when i'm on tour
i got to make sure that i keep my body
on optimal
level because there's so much that goes
into
touring and it's really hard on your
body you're doing like an hour and an
hour and a half show a night which is
similar to
a professional athlete and so with that
being said
um you just got to make sure you're
taking precautions necessary
so that you keep your body in shape so
that's why
saunas are very good
here's where i have all of my stuff for
my face
and my brushing of my teeth my good
stuff
there's a compartment downstairs down
below to keep my clothes but then
there's
some of this stuff too which is some of
this is hayley's
um someone that's mine we tend to share
clothes
over here there's some more clothes some
more clothes in here
some more clothes in here all these
little tucked away spots
[Music]
you know just some vibes
here's my shoes um
they're not all filled up but
a bunch of options in there what else do
i got in this bad boy
sorry i get caught up in the tv it's
okay
i bought this bus a year ago um and it's
been
so good because in quarantine obviously
there's
you know you're supposed to stay
socially distant so we're able to
travel in this and still be able to keep
socially distance so we did a road trip
in this bus
which was really cool we traveled from
my home in canada
all the way to my place in l.a
i just think there's there's something
about being in your own
safe comfortable environment that you
just feel
comfortable and safe and protected i
don't know
one thing i do love about this bus that
i love about
i just i just love these lights these
led
lights
favorite part of the bus well i love the
bed
this area is super cozy but i would say
my favorite part of the bus
would be this area and what i love about
this which i think is super cool
is that you can pull this out and this
becomes almost like a little
bed like this so you can just cruise
here and sit
you know it's a vibe
[Music]
the cool thing about this bus is that
it's usually with me when i'm on the
road
uh for touring stuff so
uh band comes on here dancers
um the crew and we just uh
it's a good space it's a good creative
space you're writing music on the bus
i've written some songs on the bus
not on this specific bus yet but i've
definitely written some fun songs on
the bus uh well there's a song called
memphis which i wrote
in memphis on the bus it's on
my journal's album and yeah that was on
on a tour bus
[Music]
gq thank you so much for coming to check
out my tour bus i
had a great day with you guys and i'm
looking forward to
next time peace
[Music]
um
um